TIMOTHY: How's everyone
doing today?
Are you happy to be here?
I am.
I'm just curious, how many Glass
Explorers do we have in
the audience wearing
Glass right now?
Woo.
Congratulations,
that's awesome.
OK, so this is a fireside chat
with some of the Glass team.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
I'm a Developer Advocate working
on Project Glass.
And up here I have these
wonderful people.
First off, Isabelle Olson, our
Lead Industrial Designer.
Say hi.
ISABELLE: Hi.
TIMOTHY: Charles Mendis, our
Software Engineering Director.
CHARLES: Hi.
TIMOTHY: And Steve Lee,
our Product Director.
So this is how it's
going to work.
I'm going to start with my
questions, asking Isabelle,
Charles, and Steve some things
that I get asked a lot, and
that we hear a lot from
the community--
Explorers and non
Explorers alike.
And then after that, we're going
to open up the floor
right away to hear your
questions and have a
conversation directly
with you.
Does that sound like fun?
I hope so.
We've got like 40
minutes of this.
So you better strap in.
Let's start with Isabelle.
Now, Isabelle, you've been on
Glass since, as you say--
I love this quote--
since the prototype was still
"a phone attached to a scuba
mask." I'm curious how we got
from there to here, about the
design vision that you
established for Glass, how it
brought us here, and
what's next?
ISABELLE: Sure.
You know, when the team started
working on this, it
was very clear that we're not
taking something that already
existed and making incremental
improvements to it.
The team wanted to create
something that's much more
intuitive, immediate,
and intimate.
But to create a new type of
wearable technology--
that's so ambitious, and
very messy at points.
And I will never forget the
first day on the team when I
walked into a room full of
people wearing these crazy
things on their heads.
And I brought the prototype just
you guys can see what I
walked into.
Here.
Comes in a fancy bag.
So--
I don't know what you guys
think, but this definitely
made me a little shaky.
TIMOTHY: You wear it
so well, though.
ISABELLE: You think?
I think the colors of the board
kind of fits my hair
color, but I don't know.
It's kind of heavy, though.
I think I'm going to
take it off now.
But how do you go from something
like this to what
we're all wearing today?
We took a reductionist
approach.
We removed everything that
wasn't absolutely essential.
And then in addition to that,
I formed three principles to
guide the team throughout this
ambitious, messy process.
And those are lightness,
simplicity, and scalability.
And those are not just
fancy words.
They mean something.
So when it comes to lightness,
it's fairly straightforward.
We are obsessed with weight.
Not in the same way as the
fashion industry is, but we do
care about every single gram.
Because if it's not light,
you're not going to want to
wear it for more than
10 minutes.
And it's not only about
lightness, but also about
balance, and how it's balanced
on your face.
The way we designed it with our
construction methods, and
material choices, and how we
placed the components, it
weighs less on your nose than
many sunglasses and regular
glasses on the market--
which is pretty cool.
It's not only about physical
lightness,
but also visual lightness.
We took the approach of hiding
some of the largest components
on the board behind the frame
so we could create this one,
clean, simple appearance
from the side.
When I joined the project, we
thought we needed 50 different
adjustment mechanisms.
But that wouldn't be a great
user experience, so we
simplified it down to just this
one mechanism, and this
is how it adjusts
to your head.
And then to the last point,
which is scalability.
This is what I'm the most
excited about at the moment,
and for the future of Glass.
You walk into any glasses store
and you see thousands,
to hundreds of thousands,
of different styles.
How do we deal with that?
Well, we made Glass modular.
At this stage what this means
is that you can remove the
frame from the main board.
There's a little screw here.
You unscrew it, and you can
remove it, and attach
different kinds of frames.
This is pretty cool.
This opens up a lot
of opportunities--
for prescription glasses, to
transform the functionality of
Glass, but also the
appearance of it.
So I just brought one example
of this, which is our
prescription prototype.
So you can see how different
this looks from what I was
just wearing.
So not only are we now excited
about Glass as a software
platform, but Glass as a
hardware platform as well.
TIMOTHY: Awesome.
Thank you, Isabelle.
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY: Charles, you're next.
When I first joined the team,
there was something that you
and I talked about a lot.
It's something that you
felt passionate about.
They make the chairs dangerous
on purpose.
I don't know why.
Glass was both a device
and a platform.
I think that's really
interesting.
I was hoping that you could
speak to the first
principles--
your first principles-- for that
platform, what the Mirror
API was built for, and maybe a
little bit about the upcoming
Glass Development Kit we touched
on earlier today.
CHARLES: Absolutely.
We want Glass to have a big,
positive impact in the world.
And I'm a platforms guy.
I was lucky to be part of the
Android team in the early
days, and I was amazed by all
the great things that
developers built on top of the
Android platform, and all the
innovation it really drove.
I think most of you actually
have an Android phone in your
pocket today.
I believe Glass in developers'
hands will have a similar
impact and drive innovation
again.
We built Glass, not just for
developers, but for us, too.
So the core principle behind
Glass is that we build on top
of the exact same APIs you do.
For example, let's take some of
Google's flagship products--
Google+, Gmail, Google Now.
They build on top of the exact
same APIs that Facebook and
Twitter release their
apps today on.
We don't have anything extra.
We use the Mirror API
just like them.
And that's our core
philosophy.
Taking that, we want to
apply the exact same
philosophy to the GDK--
the Glass Developer Kit.
But for that we need
your help.
We want to know what the Glass
explorers do with the device,
what apps you built on top of
it, what APIs you hack on, and
see what all the services
you develop.
And then build an API that takes
that into account, and
help us shape the GDK.
It'll take a while.
It won't be coming out soon
because we really want to
listen to your feedback
and incorporate it in.
But, honestly, I can't wait
to get it into your hands.
TIMOTHY: Awesome.
Thank you, Charles.
Next up is Steve.
Steve, let's talk about
the Explorer program.
This is a super unique way
to introduce a product.
You could say unprecedented.
Can you tell us what the
Explorer program is, and why
it makes sense for Glass?
STEVE: Sure, Timothy.
Well, first of all, just
stepping back, I think the
reason why we're up here and why
the larger Glass team is
working so hard on Glass is
because we really believe that
Glass can transform how
people use technology.
We think it's a really
big idea.
And the Explorer program is an
important part of how we're
bringing Glass to the world.
We see the Explorer program
as a way to learn the
possibilities with Glass.
One of my most memorable
experiences with Glass
happened a few weeks ago.
I found myself at Disneyland in
the front row of a roller
coaster sporting Glass.
I was going, screaming 55 miles
per hour, on this roller
coaster with a full upside down
loop, hands in the air.
And I was able to capture that
entire experience, and then
share it later with family
and friends.
I just found that super,
super compelling.
This is one of the many exciting
things that I've done
with Glass.
And with the Explorer program,
where we're at right now is
we're now getting into the hands
of thousands of other
people to see what exciting
things they can do with Glass.
The first group of people that
we're getting it into the
hands of are developers.
And, as Timothy showed a few
minutes ago with a survey,
many of you in the audience
are already Explorers.
We know that to fully realize
the potential of Glass, we
need your help.
We need developers to innovate
on the platform.
About a month ago we started
distributing
Glass to our Explorers.
I'm happy to say that earlier
this week-- right before
Google I/O-- we've invited all
2,000 people who signed up at
last year's I/O to come pick
up their Glass device.
We're very happy about that.
[APPLAUSE]
STEVE: And the next group of
people that will become
Explorers are the folks who
signed up for hashtag
#ifihadglass.
There were 8,000 people selected
from over 100,000
people who applied.
And we will soon be rolling out
invites to those folks to
pick up Glass.
What's exciting about that
group of people--
they're not developers,
but it's a nice
cross section of people.
We have folks who
are educators.
They're teachers.
We have athletes.
We have DJs, dentists,
hairstylists--
all kinds of different people.
So we're really excited to see
what a diverse set of folks,
what are they going
to do with Glass.
And the last thing I'd like to
say about the Explorer program
is that our team--
we're excited about the Explorer
program because we're
going to be listening to you.
We're going to be listening to
Explorers, learning from your
experiences, and improving
Glass.
One concrete thing we'll be
doing is that each and every
month the software team,
Charles's team, will be
rolling out software updates
to all Explorers.
And those software
updates will--
[APPLAUSE]
STEVE: --those software
updates will have new
features, will add more polish,
will fix bugs, and
will specifically be
incorporating changes based on
your feedback.
TIMOTHY: Awesome.
Thank you, Steve.
OK, I have one more question,
and it's for each of you
before we get to audience
questions.
And that is--
let's put it this way.
If you could ask the developers
in the room to
build one thing for you on
Glass, what would it be?
Let's start with Steve.
STEVE: I have a lot of
ideas No, Charles's
team and the team--
we've done a good job at
focusing on the core set of
applications you might want.
But there are so many
possibilities--
we're just scratching
the surface.
If I have to name one, though,
I'm a big exercise fanatic.
I love to go cycling,
and running, and a
lot of fitness things.
Today I have a Garmin GPS
sports watch with
a heart rate monitor.
I wear a strap around
my chest.
I'd love to have a fitness
application on Glass and
integrate, not only the software
application, but
integrate it with my heart
rate monitor as well.
That way I could have
information relevant to my
workout right in front of my
eyes as I'm working out.
I don't have to break stride
while I'm running to look down
at my wrist.
And if I'm cycling, it'd be much
safer because I can keep
my eyes on the road.
So that's what I'd love
to see happen.
TIMOTHY: Charles?
CHARLES: Yeah, for me, I think
I'd love a way to pay easily
at the cash register.
I have two young kids, like
a five-year-old and a
three-year-old.
They're grabbing stuff from
all over the shelf.
And I'm like, no, stop that.
You know, trying to
keep it together.
And then on top of that, I have
to pull out my wallet
which means one of them
will run free.
There's going to be
consequences.
So I'd love to be able to just
have them say, OK, here's the
price here.
Yup.
Pay, done, and move on.
I think it should be
as simple as that.
ISABELLE: Well, those are
really good examples.
I'm really into karaoke.
Seriously, though, if there
was a way to sing karaoke
where you actually face
the audience--
which is usually your
drunk friends--
instead of staring into a screen
with words on it, I
think that would be awesome.
Please make it.
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY: Awesome.
OK.
So let's get to your
questions.
A couple of notes
before we start.
First off, you know this
is really common.
We get feature requests
all the time.
That's good.
We definitely want them.
We want to know how we can make
the API better, and how
we make the GDK that we're going
to release in the future
the best GDK that
you can have.
However, none of us are going
to be able to comment on
future plans.
So, whereas we'd love to hear
the feature requests-- please
say them-- we won't be able to
comment on whether we will,
will not make them, or what
they'll look like.
AUDIENCE: Why not?
TIMOTHY: As a policy, at Google
we don't comment on
future looking plans.
All right.
[LAUGHTER]
TIMOTHY: And I follow rules--
at least that one.
Anyway, the next thing is we
don't have an updated timeline
for Glass release.
Where we're at right
now is that--
well, let me say this.
I've had a number of people come
to me at Google I/O, and
be like, I want Glass, and
I have this amazing idea.
And my first reaction is, I
want you to have Glass.
And that's our goal.
It's only a matter of time.
Right now we're selling Glass to
the Explorers who signed up
at Google I/O last year.
Next, it's the #ifihadglass
people.
Next, it could be you.
If you want to make sure that
we contact you when there's
more availability, go to
google.com slash Glass, and
there's a form on there
where you can
indicate your interest.
That said, everything
else is fair game.
[INAUDIBLE]
during this Explorer period,
we're really interested in
your feedback, and having a
conversation around how Glass
can be amazing for everyone.
Fireside chats can be
a little crazy.
But we felt strongly that we
wanted to come up here and
have a conversation, because
that's what this
period is all about.
So please, there's two
microphones, one in each of
these aisles.
We're going to go
back and forth.
Let's hear you have to say.
First right here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Amir Efrati from the "Wall
Street Journal." This is for
any of you, but Steve--
you might want to
take the lead.
I'm curious what you think and
what kind of thinking you've
done about the privacy
implications of the device,
whether this is different than
a smartphone or not, and how
much of the data that's captured
by this device will
be kept by Google?
How much of the user generated
data will be kept by Google?
TIMOTHY: OK.
So two questions there.
One is what are the privacy
implications and can
you speak to that?
And the second thing is user
data and what we do with it.
STEVE: Sure.
I've been on the project since
the beginning, for almost
three years now.
So I have a pretty good view of
how the product's evolved
and what the team philosophy
has been.
And I can definitely say that,
from the beginning, the social
implications and social
etiquette of Glass--
of people wearing Glass--
has been at the top of our mind
in how we designed and
developed the product.
And, not only thinking about
the people who will buy and
use Glass-- be wearing Glass--
but really everyone, and the
implications for those around
the people wearing Glass.
I'm proud of the team for
taking it seriously and
thinking about that early on.
Let me just give a few examples
of how the design's
evolved to accommodate
some of that.
One is-- and I think Isabelle
mentioned this earlier--
that the display is up above
the person's eye.
We learned that very
early on--
some of our early prototypes
actually covered your eyes.
We quickly discovered how
important human eye contact is
with other people around you.
Another common question
is about distractions.
Is Glass distracting?
How do I know if you're paying
attention to me?
Typically people who are asking
that haven't been
around someone with Glass yet.
Because once you're around
someone with Glass--
you'll know that they're
paying attention to you
because they're looking
at you.
You have eye contact.
And if you're looking at Glass,
you're looking up at
the display.
So that's one example
of design.
A second thing is
with the camera.
A lot of the privacy questions
are around the camera, and
picture taking, and videos.
That's why to start recording a
video, or to take a picture,
the way you do it has
clear social cues
and a social gesture.
There's a camera button right
here, so I have to raise my
hand, press the button
to take a picture.
Or speak to Glass and say, OK,
Glass, take a picture, or, OK,
Glass, record a video.
So it's a very clear cue to
other people around you.
The third example that I'd
like to give is that--
and this is something I want
to really educate people on
about how Glass works--
is that when Glass is active,
the display lights up.
It not only lights up for me
to see, but other observers
can see that as well.
So right now you can't see a
light emitting from Glass
because it's not active.
So because of that you can
rest assured that I'm not
recording you right now.
AUDIENCE: Though it could
be hacked, right,
just like any device?
STEVE: Yes.
I mean, that's on Charles.
[LAUGHTER]
STEVE: We take the trust and
reliability of our software
very seriously--
like all other teams
at Google.
So by design, that's
not intended.
Our design is to ensure
the display is active
when Glass is active.
And that'll be part
of our GDK.
It'll also be part
of our policy.
So applications won't be
permitted that don't do that.
CHARLES: And just to add to that
on the social cues, if
I'm recording a video of you
with Glass, I have to be
staring at you.
If I look anywhere, I'm
recording here.
I have to stare at you.
And as a human being, if
someone's staring at you, you
kind of notice.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLES: Like a girl's walking
down the street, and the guy's
just like--
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLES: Yeah, so I think
there's definitely going to be
social cues.
And, again, I've heard the
thing about the restroom.
If you walk into the restroom,
even without Glass, if
somebody's just looking
at you.
I don't know about you,
but I'm going to get
the hell out of there.
AUDIENCE: Not to hijack this
whole thing, but when you have
facial recognition technology
that's capturing people's
information, is that something
you think about as well?
TIMOTHY: OK, so that's
your third question.
We're going to stop there.
So the other question he asked
was about data and I guess
also about facial recognition.
STEVE: Sure.
So to the second question,
I think it's fairly
straightforward regarding
use of user data.
On the Glass team, we're
following the same policies
and principles that the
rest of Google does.
We're not really deviating
from that.
So I think that's the answer
to that question.
I'll take the face recognition
question as well.
That's something that we've
prototyped early on.
We definitely experimented
with it.
But it's not something that's
part of the product today.
It's not currently in
our product plan.
I think at some point in the
future, whether Google's
developing it or third party
developers, I can
imagine that existing.
Me being a product person--
the way I view it--
I'm not scared of it, but I want
to make sure that there's
clear user benefit.
That's just super compelling.
And if it's super compelling
for people, then I think
there's something there.
That's one thing, and
then secondly--
let's be honest and genuine
about the privacy issues and
what policy would surround
that type of feature.
But currently there's no plans
for us to do that.
TIMOTHY: Great.
All right.
Question from over here.
AUDIENCE: I'm Sheldon.
I had seven questions.
[LAUGHTER]
TIMOTHY: You may ask one now.
AUDIENCE: OK.
TIMOTHY: And then you can go--
AUDIENCE: It's kind
of two questions.
First of all, is the
side multi-touch?
And if it is, wouldn't it be
cool if we could pull down
with two fingers to
delete cards?
Because some of the cards
are kind of annoying.
I mean, just because Google Now
puts them in there whether
you like it or not.
Like you might take a picture
and share it, and then you
just want it to go away.
There's lots of times where
you want to do that.
And I thought, well, if it was
multi-touch, you could just
swipe down with two fingers
and get rid of it.
I know you can't talk about
features, or if that's a
feature or whatever, but
I did talk to somebody
at the Glass booth.
That was sort of like a decision
about what that down
gesture was going to
be and how you were
going to handle that.
So I just want to put
that out there.
TIMOTHY: So I think the general
question there-- and I
think this is great
for Charles--
which is gestures on the touch
pad, both in the system
software and exposed
in the GDK.
CHARLES: Yeah, definitely.
Just keep in mind this is an
early developer version.
We made it for developers.
So there will be a
lot of changes.
As Steve mentioned, every month
we will do an update.
Is it multi-touch?
Yes, absolutely.
Will we maybe use that gesture?
Maybe.
It's one of those things where
we want to listen to your
feedback, take it in,
and really think,
does it make sense?
And in that feature in general,
I'd be thinking, can
we improve Google Now so we do
show you better cards so you
don't need to do that?
Because I actually feel like if
you have to do that, in a
sense we've kind of failed.
Because we've shown you
something, wasted your time,
and with Glass-- again, coming
back to Isabelle's--
it's about simplicity, quick,
micro-interactions.
I worry a little bit if we're
pushing you content and making
you do that.
AUDIENCE: Well, the case for
that one was I just happened
to search for Walker Creek Ranch
or something because I
was looking at going to
a conference up there.
And it wanted to give
me directions there.
I came to San Francisco and
it was like, oh, you're
only an hour away.
Head on up there.
Usually, almost all of the
time, when I search for
something, I actually do want to
know the directions there,
and it's really convenient.
But in this particular case, I
was just searching it as a
research thing, you know?
So 90% of the time
it's perfect.
And only 10% of the time would
I want to say, oh, I didn't
really mean that.
Do you know what I mean?
So don't mess with Google Now.
TIMOTHY: Thank you
for the feedback.
STEVE: I'd also quickly point
out that actually the two
finger swipe down gesture is
already part of the product.
AUDIENCE: What does it do?
STEVE: It dismisses
the display.
So one finger swipe down goes
back, which can sometimes
dismiss the display.
Two fingers--
AUDIENCE: Always dismisses
[? it? ?]
STEVE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Oh, nice.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: That was fast.
STEVE: Charles works wonders.
TIMOTHY: Team moves quick.
STEVE: He's coding on
Glass right now.
[INAUDIBLE]
TIMOTHY: OK.
Question from over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Michael Moussa.
I'm an Android developer.
And I have a question kind
of related to the GDK.
I was in the hacking Glass
session, the last session, and
my question is--
it was mentioned as a 640 by I
think 360 display, that's 8
feet out, 25 inches.
And I remember from the
Google TV [INAUDIBLE]
TV experience there's some
conversion to get it.
So my question is what's the
equivalent screen size and
what resolution should we target
for our resources?
CHARLES: HDPI.
AUDIENCE: HDPI?
CHARLES: Target HDPI.
Assume you've got 640 by 360.
AUDIENCE: HDPI normal
screen size?
TIMOTHY: Nice.
That was a good one.
OK, over here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
about voice triggers.
And I guess specifically, as a
suggestion, I can imagine with
the API people are obviously
going to want to be able to
create their own voice triggers
so that you don't
actually to go to the card
to activate the feature.
So my question is have you
thought about how that's going
to be managed, and whether or
not you're going to have
different apps that are kind
of competing for the same
voice trigger or similar
voice triggers?
TIMOTHY: That's a great
question, and it's about voice
invocation.
CHARLES: Yeah, it's definitely
something we're talking about.
We haven't really made a
decision on it, but it's kind
of top of our mind right now.
So again coming back to we
don't really want to
foreshadow features, but we
definitely do want a way for
you to voice trigger things
and we're just exploring
different ways to do it.
Because like you said, there
could be a lot of apps that
want to do the same thing.
Uber is a great example.
Should we get a taxi?
But there are a lot
of taxi companies.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you.
TIMOTHY: Thank you.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: How are you doing?
Paul Forgione.
I'm just a lowly student.
But this is a question for you,
Isabelle, in regards to
the industrial design.
You were showing the prototype
that you had, and then you're
wearing a bright orange
pair right now.
Tim, you have the blue pair on,
then you were showing the
prescription glasses prototype
you guys have.
Obviously over time the
components are going to shrink
and soon get smaller.
Are you planning on sort of
trying to incorporate it and
make it less noticeable?
Or are you going to move forward
with the direction
with the bright colors and
continue to still have it be a
statement while you're
wearing it?
ISABELLE: We've developed five
different colors to kind of
satisfy different personalities
and also what
you look good in.
It's kind of counter-intuitive.
A lot of people think,
oh, charcoal.
That's going to go
with everything.
That's my favorite color.
And me, myself, because
I wear a lot of black.
But then after wearing it around
for almost a year,
different colors, we started
to see how important color
was, and how non-intuitive it
was, and like how people
develop an attachment to
the specific color.
Every time we do a new prototype
and all the colors
are not available, people come
and then scream at me.
I want my tangerine back.
And I'm like, I can't do
anything about that.
We chose five.
We didn't want to overwhelm
people, and there was a range.
So we have a couple of bright
ones and then we have three
kind of neutrals.
And I think the cotton one is
kind of bold and neutral at
the same time.
And shale looks great on almost
everybody and is a
little bit less heavy
than charcoal.
Although Charles--
CHARLES: I love charcoal.
ISABELLE: --rocked charcoal
because he has dark skin, so
it looks really good.
TIMOTHY: I don't know.
Blue's pretty nice.
STEVE: I think what Isabelle's
saying, though, is that the
look is very important.
ISABELLE: Yeah, and I think
colors are much more important
than you would ever imagine.
And if it's up to me, I would
want to keep on doing cool
colors, and keep
on doing that.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you.
TIMOTHY: Thank you.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, my question
is about displays.
Can you comment on how does
the display work?
Is it a projector?
Or is it a small LCD screen
that's reflecting off a prism?
And the second part to it is
do you see people using it
only for micro-interactions,
or is it for long form
reading, video?
TIMOTHY: OK, so there's two
questions, and I think it's
Charles and Steve.
The first question is, can you
talk about the technical
specifications of the display?
CHARLES: Yeah, we don't really
want to get into the technical
details of that right now.
AUDIENCE: Well, just on the
principle of how does it work,
is it just reflecting off
or is it a projector?
CHARLES: Yeah, I really don't
want to comment on the
technical data.
AUDIENCE: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
TIMOTHY: And then the second
question is to Steve.
STEVE: Yeah.
I mean, while we can't
[INAUDIBLE]
the technology, but what the
experience is like is it--
because a common question for
those who've not tried Glass
on is, do I have to focus
on something a
centimeter from my eye?
And no, you don't
have to do that.
That would be painful.
It projects it out six or seven
feet in front of you, a
virtual image.
TIMOTHY: That's how it feels.
STEVE: That's how it feels.
The second question--
in terms of duration of looking
at the display.
It's definitely true, by putting
the display up above
your eye, it's not intended to,
for example, watch a full
length movie or read a book.
It would be uncomfortable.
Humans aren't used to looking
up for that long a period.
So we've designed the entire
experience around brief
interactions.
We call them on the team
micro-interactions.
And that's not only just
because of the display
placement, but it also fits with
our goal of the product,
which is really to allow you to
get technology out of the
way when you don't need it.
When you're trying to experience
life, and do
activities in life, we don't
want to create zombies staring
at a display for long
periods of time.
So we really tried to design
Glass to be fast and brief
moments of experience.
TIMOTHY: Cool.
All right, over here.
AUDIENCE: My name's Tristan.
I'm from Portland, Oregon.
And I was also wondering
about colors.
I was wondering how you settled
on the first five
colors, and if you tested a
number of different colors
first and then sort of
winnowed them down to
what we have now?
And I also wanted to suggest a
green color as the next color.
I was thinking perhaps Pantone
377C is pretty close
[INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
ISABELLE: Will you
write that down?
TIMOTHY: Say it one more time?
AUDIENCE: 377C.
ISABELLE: Is that [INAUDIBLE]
coated one?
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure.
ISABELLE: So the question
is how we
arrived at these colors.
I think one of the benefits
we've had with the way we've
done the project is we've
built all these monthly
prototypes.
Every month we would come out
with a new prototype and
everybody on the team has
been wearing them.
So what we did quite
early on was to
produce a range of colors--
just two of each--
and then I basically looked
at which colors are people
fighting over.
It's kind of a fun indication.
So that was kind of a way to
see what was really popular
and what resonated
with people.
I mean, we have a very
diverse team.
So just by observing, seeing
people wearing it around,
seeing what works, seeing
what doesn't work.
I would force people to try
on different things.
So it's kind of an intuition,
and having an eye for it, and
just kind of experimenting.
And, again, we wanted a few
poppy colors for people who
are like, hey, come
and talk to me.
And then a more subdued for
people who kind of want to
stand out a little bit less.
TIMOTHY: Thank you.
ISABELLE: Thanks.
TIMOTHY: Awesome question.
I liked that one.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Eric from
Vancouver, Canada.
My question was mostly
about like--
and I think I speak for
most people here--
using such a different device,
and using such a personal
device, isn't a problem
for most people here.
But how does Glass plan to get
to people who aren't so into
technology and who aren't
so indulgent in
trying the newest things.
How are you going to show
that Glass is something
more than just that?
TIMOTHY: Let me just ask
a specific question.
Do you mean getting them
Glass physically?
Or do you mean sort of how are
they going to integrate it
into their lives?
AUDIENCE: I mean like them using
it, not actually them
getting hold of it.
I mean in the future.
TIMOTHY: Yeah.
Steve.
STEVE: I'll take that.
Sure.
We announced our project
a little over a
year ago to the world.
And we did that relatively early
in the development of
Glass, which is not sort of
standard to do it that way.
We did that though for
a couple reasons.
One, we felt like to build the
best possible product, this is
something we couldn't do in
a secret lab at Google.
We had to get out in the
real world, ourselves--
wear it, use it, and improve
the product.
And, secondly, is just to
understand the social
applications and reactions from
other people better, and
educate society on why we think
this is a good thing for
people and society.
One thing that I'm quite
surprised by is how quickly
that there's been a positive
reaction, not just from people
in Silicon Valley or at Google,
but around the world.
So I'm wearing Glass
all over the place.
Not just here in the Bay Area,
not just in New York and LA,
but I'm from Iowa.
So I go back home in Iowa.
I'm from a town of 1,200 people,
and the response from
folks there is--
similar to New York, LA, here,
anywhere else-- with
incredible optimism
and excitement.
These are not developers.
It's not people who read "The
Verge" or "TechCrunch." This
is normal folks.
[LAUGHTER]
STEVE: And they are very, very
optimistic, intrigued, and
curious about Glass.
They can see and incorporate
it in their life.
They're still trying
to understand
exactly what it does.
And as we slowly reveal what
Glass is, and, frankly, learn
ourselves what all it can do,
I think they're learning.
But I think there's already
interest and intrigue.
So I actually think there's a
real opportunity for Glass to
become mainstream.
ISABELLE: And that's also
what [INAUDIBLE]
a Glass program is
about as well--
a very diverse group, not very
techie, and who'll be our
first other types of
people using it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
TIMOTHY: Thank you.
And over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name
is Rick Merit.
I'm a reporter with
"Electronic Engineering Times"--
EE Times.
And I guess what my readers
would most like to know,
because they'll be the folks who
are some day building this
kind of product or building
the components--
the displays, and the batteries,
and the chips that
power them.
What they would most like is as
much commentary and color
that you want to give them
and tell them about--
I suppose what's working is not
as interesting as what's
not working-- what you need
better in terms of battery, or
performance, or display, or
whatever componentry.
What you need from that
community that you're not
getting or what you most need
in the future, what do you
most want, your wish list.
TIMOTHY: Charles, I think
this is for you.
CHARLES: I think that's a great
question because I think
Glass will drive forward certain
types of technologies.
And, at least right now, I
don't think they're any
different to what you'd want
from a cell phone.
I mean, you guys are probably
power users of your cell
phone, and one of the biggest
things is the battery.
I mean, battery density and
capacity isn't really doubling
every year.
It's not really becoming smaller
and 10 times more
powerful like processors
did back in the day.
So I think that battery
technology is kind of key.
Or power technology--
maybe it's not battery.
Maybe it's some other source.
But I really hope
there's a lot of
investment in that area.
And I think that's going to be
key to powering a lot of
great, new experiences, and
having a tiny form factor.
TIMOTHY: OK, I think we
have time for maybe
one or two more questions.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
This is Emerson from Toronto.
I was wondering whether the
Glass team has had any worries
about parallels to, say,
Bluetooth headset, where it
was very fashionable
after a while.
But people thought that people
on Bluetooth headsets were
crazy because they were
talking to themselves.
And eventually Bluetooth
headsets became not so
fashionable, and aren't
doing so well anymore.
TIMOTHY: So is the question is
Glass going to be fashionable?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I'm sure it will be,
but I was wondering if like
you predicted ahead and see if
there might be a worrisome
downward trend of Glass after
an initial hot start--
after the initial burst
of enthusiasm, as
you mentioned earlier.
STEVE: Yeah, that's definitely
something we've about, and
specifically thinking about
Bluetooth headsets.
Like I just said, we hope and
expect Glass to become popular
with mainstream.
To do that, to achieve that, I
think it needs to be thought
of as something positive.
And not just by people who buy
and use Glass, but by those
around them.
And I do think it's pretty
common with Bluetooth--
I've yet to meet a person who
says that they like being
around someone who has a
Bluetooth headset on.
It's usually not a
positive image.
And we want to do the exact
opposite with Glass.
So to achieve that I think that
it's really important--
number one-- some
of the things we
talked about earlier.
Social etiquette and how can
we design Glass to make it
more personable and more social,
and not taking you out
of the moment--
actually keeping you in the
moment-- with those that
you're around.
That's number one.
That's a key design
tenant for us.
And number two is how can Glass
benefit those around you
or other people, even if
they don't have Glass.
And so already we have a few
experiences that do that.
Since it's so good at capturing
moments of events
that you might be at or
activities you're doing, you
can share them with the people
you're with, and they see
benefit with Glass.
Another great thing about Glass
is instant access to
information.
Often when you're with friends
or family, questions will
arise, or you'd like
to know something.
And Glass is so fast at getting
that information, all
of a sudden you become the
hero instead of the goat.
Those are just a couple
examples already.
But again, getting back to the
development community, that's
one thing I'd love to see
developers think about.
How can you not only make Glass
great for the person
using Glass, but for everyone
they're with?
TIMOTHY: All right.
And with that we are at time.
There's a couple things I'd
like to say before we go,
because the conversation doesn't
have to stop here.
If you're an Explorer, we have
a community for you online.
It's glass-community.com.
Please join us there.
Let's continue talking
about these things as
we build Glass together.
If you're a developer, you can
ask questions on "Stack
Overflow." The tag is Glass.
And of course all of us are
available on Google+ if you
want to join us on there.
Thank you so much, and we look
forward to our next chat.
[APPLAUSE]